[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prigoncour 1993 pour le rocher de tagos
Amin malouf a vécu 27 ans au Liban où il
est né avant que de s'installer en
France en pleine guerre du Liban en 1976
il appartient à une famille à la fois
arabe et chrétienne sa langue maternelle
et l'arabe il écrit son œuvre en
français c'est donc par excellence un
homme de passage ce qu'il vit non pas
comme un handicap mais comme un
enrichissement d'où cet essai publié
chez grassy les identités
[Musique]
meurtrières avec moi aujourd'hui ici
même au Liban dans le cœur de la Biblos
antique André berkov journaliste et
écrivain français lui aussi né dans ce
pays est venu à Paris en 1967 à peu près
au même âge qu'Amine malouf alors André
vous aussi vous avez lu les identités
meurtrières quel sentiment cet ouvrage
vous aspiret-il bien ce ne sont pas les
identités qui sont meurtrières mais ceux
qui nous utilisent pour réduire les
hommes ou des femmes à leur
particularité vous savez Olivier on est
au Liban qui pendant 15 ans a connu une
guerre identitaire terrifiante
fraternelle civile on appppelle ça
guerre civile qui a fait que les gens se
massacré au nom de leur appartenance
religieuse ethnique culturelle politique
économique et bien justement il faut
arrêter cela il faut que n'oublie pas
qu'un homme est d'abord supérieur à la
somme de ses particularités et les
identités meurtrières si on veut les
détruire c'est justement en pensant à
l'être humain d'abord je crois que c'est
ça le sens du
[Musique]
livre